okay hi everyone we are talking about
elegant code
and its rendering
so let's take a look oh yeah let's take
a look at some of these
um
that's pretty nice looking actually I
think could you go back to standard size
uh oh yeah sure
okay go go back to the larger again
150 that I was at
um
do we have some code that was written by
uh Church BT
or I don't have any uh there must be
some in that post that I wrote
um
uh Michael just sent something uh let me
but this is this is my this is my one
that's not GTP I I can provide one in
five minutes
yeah with all of its commenting and so
on
uh okay so scroll down a bit
and and by the way I assume that this
font whatever it is what is that font
anyway
uh
uh so this s
so the the uh the map font is Wolfram
modern uh what is the base font Jeremy I
don't remember it's effectively Source
hands Pro but it's got a toggle to make
it mono right so it's called Source Sans
code
right right and with my changes we
probably won't need to do that
uh because uh I I I'm
that's what one of the things that I
added was a parameterization that I mean
you were doing that because you wanted
to be able to pick up the uh monospace
version of the of the wolf and fox and
right right I I now have that completely
parameterizable okay
that slash hat looks really sucky there
foreign
sorry oh here here yeah yeah
um so now you you sent email with
something that was kind of similar to
this and in that case I think it had to
do with uh you know maybe spacing you
know like this sort of spacing and such
I mean you know this is the consequence
of taking a uh you know sort of a a
shotgun Approach at just uh monospacing
all the operators
well we could make that operator not be
I mean we don't have to make inside the
operator it doesn't have to be monospace
does it
Yeah It's Tricky
it seems like it can't possibly work to
be monos based inside the operator if
you type just type on a new line X
yeah but at is taking the full width of
the mono space f slash slash X yeah
that's sucky yeah yeah and the arrow is
too bold
which arrow or any
yeah
my ideas goes only to the arrows the
only thing I see when I look at this
[Laughter]
um oh well you know why that is because
we grade down these guys but it doesn't
look like I grade this down
yeah so that's that's fixable
right
Michael Christopher others
you know on the surface this looks quite
elegant but I'm worried that the that
not knowing where there's a brace and
where there's a bracket
question is okay here's the real thing
here
is there an implicit semantic grammar of
Orphan language
that is in our heads we know that most
of those brackets have to be brackets
they can't be braces there's very little
ambiguity
if you understand what I mean so you
barely need them
you know you need them only
to precisely Define what you mean in
other words does redundancy in the way
that those are there and therefore if we
gray them it's not going to make any
difference
do you agree with that statement or to
what extent
do you like need the bracket need the
braces to understand what's going on and
to what extent is it like you could just
fill it in in your mind easily enough
you definitely need to praise this no no
you need them I mean Michael you need
them the question is whether when you
first read this your first impression
for example in that list plot those
braces strike me as more necessary than
the square brackets
and I'm kind of wondering if the braces
should be darker than the square
brackets
because I think square brackets they you
know you can always fill in where they
have to be
if you make if you if you see what I'm
saying yeah I think you know what you
mean
I mean commas similarly John do we have
any control over this in real time can
we can we make the bases darker
well it's everything uh no that's not
gonna work so I mean because I mean well
sorry what I mean is all of the gray
operators would great would would change
color together okay but fine but that's
not what I was looking for what I'm
saying is I will make an argument as I'm
looking at this that the square brackets
are purely
sort of they're like
they're like guidelines of some kind
they're like they're like you know the
the you know the little blue lines on on
um paper or something the the things
that are useful
you know that
they're just infrastructure
whereas I claim that the braces and the
commas are more important
making sense
well just yeah go ahead like if you see
salt
opening Square random for example I
think they're the spacing looks pretty
good but on the left list spots Square
curly that looks too large for me that
looks unpleasantly large
well it might not look so large if the
brace was darker
I don't think the spacing is so terrible
I have to say I mean I think oops made
it later sorry meant to make it darker
there we go
yeah well
I mean that doesn't really have the
effect because because everybody's a
good darker yeah right yeah yeah so make
it make it back to the lighter again
okay
there we go yeah so I think having the
braces be darker will be useful slightly
darker
and I think the commas as well
especially because they're kind of small
so
um the I mean you know we talked about
the the rule characters popping
uh of course now that that's
you know the only things that the only
operators that I touched were basically
the match fix operators and the commas
uh I mean you know they're you know like
you know that's still black as well and
that's still black as well and so on no
that's okay I mean that's okay I think
those are black I think that the
multi-character operators have to be
tweaked
slash that and those things those have
to be tweaked
um
uh if you want I can drop some more code
that Michael sent me from chat GPT yeah
fine
and then scroll scroll down this one to
just see this one
um
now let's take a look at Christopher's
one and so on yeah
there we go
looks pretty nice to me
there's quite a lot of code here I'll
screw up a bit
Michael what do you think I think this
looks significantly nicer than it would
do if everything was black and and more
closely spaced I agree I wouldn't mind a
little bit more color difference of the
comments
like the comments now look a little bit
too much like user functions to me
well I mean there's also the possibility
of a different font for comments
is there a possibility of a different
form oh absolutely absolutely
um
yeah I mean give me give me something
and I'll throw it in
uh I don't know uh Jeremy what do you
think
I I don't know I it's Source I don't
think another similar Sans would work if
you just want to see something different
you throw in Georgia it'll just be a
Seraph
what was that that was just a size
change
okay
uh okay fine
and we sure
just Georgia right yeah
there we go
reminds me of that program
it does seem like a lot of the brackets
are really far apart
but is that a problem
I mean I think both the the close
brackets at the end like with her four
you know five close brackets I think
that looks a little strange but also
like if you look at the plot Open
Bracket open list
in the plot all six functions together I
think that looks pretty weird
it looks
very readable I mean it the fact that it
looks unusual I mean it's gonna look
different the question is whether it
looks more attractive you know more
because I feel like the floor ceiling
square root blah blah blah blah it just
looks more literate than it did before
well I don't know I think it's I think
I mean the useful thing is when you can
sort of semantically have some things be
closer and some things be further
right which there already is a bit of
with some of the sort of Auto formatting
stuff and input cells there we go there
we go I I set font tracking just on the
uh uh the structure operators
I can get even a little more uh what
does that what does that just do
um I'd set font tracking on everything
to get better
letter spacing or the font it was tight
but it yeah I was adding a little bit
too much space for the operators yeah so
so this is font tracking just on the on
the gray stuff
characters
like on the rightmost X range I don't
like them yes how does it look wrong
which ones near the bottom
the thing that sticks out furthest to
the right
they basically touch the e
yeah that's wrong yeah yeah
uh yeah I can I can blow it out a bit
too I just I never remember what the
values are I have to go look them up
um condensed semi-condensed okay that's
that's good it's not something you can
do in real time to make the uh the
braces darker is it
uh
uh yeah it's all the gray stuff together
but I can make any changes to all the
gray stuff together at once
um
okay
so this is
tighter than normal but only marginally
tighter than normal
um sorry what were you doing I'm sorry I
just I I just loosened up the font
tracking so
uh on the structure operators or with
what I've been calling them you know the
match fix and commas so it's tighter
than normal tracking but only a little
bit
I'm totally confused what what as
opposed to that
so that's normal tracking okay now go
back
okay
um
I think yeah here we go
could you scroll up and show some of
that older code we were looking at sure
um the yeah
um the stuff from Jeremy for example
I think it will help to have the braces
be darker
than the commas
okay
um and and remember that okay that's a
little darker I can go darker yeah
because you're adjusting everything
yeah
okay right but that but I'm I'm just I'm
saying I think A variation of the
darkness of the brace relative to the
bracket will be important oh okay okay
yeah
okay can you hit a couple of Pawn
teasers somewhere
yeah
at around some characters or some
function just a couple of parenthesis
okay
let's see
yeah
there you go
they seem to have a much wider spacing
than the one we saw earlier with the
comments they were very tight
yo okay we didn't finish the discussion
about comments
right
uh what about here's another crazy idea
for you
maybe it's not doable what about a
background color for the comments
sure yeah it's totally doable uh let me
let me get a comment on screen
um
okay where there are no comments in this
section you can make a comment there
Michael had lots of comments
yeah get rid of the Georgia bring it
back too
um
and also it doesn't help that the
spacing of the the parent star is crazy
uh
uh yeah yeah that I can't do anything
about
um let's see
um so we want background give me a color
um Jeremy
very very light
um
very very light blue
okay
um
oh
it's too late apparently
um
you got something oh that's
um that's
um
Jeremy do you think this is going to
work or do you think it's crazy
I'm worried the padding's gonna be
really tight and make it look ugly
I see
he might be right
what else can we do to these sorry sorry
that's uh I expected to be able to
change the background and it's not and
I'm not sure why
um
the yeah I'm not sure why okay all right
Jeremy what else can we do here with
these I mean what about changing the
font tracking a lot for these for these
things to make them much more textual
and much less
including plain text or no is it code
is that a font style now John without
the mono
uh so it is
um
it's using the same font as uh as this
you know so yeah maybe it's a clean
Source No Mono right won't change much
but the brackets will and try to change
um maybe italic too
yeah uh no I don't think so sorry you
want what source code Pro Source hands
or Source Sands
I like
not metallic no
I think that's a faux italic that
doesn't look real to me
it's also I mean this isn't uh we're
talking about changing the tracking so
this is
yeah code you have to get rid of the
fonts but the TR the left font tracking
okay
um
the I mean you want it tighter yeah
normal
I don't think it's that way no no that
was that was normal oh boy that's that's
super tight
okay loosen it a bit but this is much
better
this is what we want
is that looser again okay there
that's much better
to my mind and then that really
distinguishes it from the code
don't you think anybody else
Jeremy I think it's maybe a little tight
it's better it's a little too tight I
could see it being slightly smaller too
yeah I think I agree slightly smaller
will be good although we're looking at
this in a magnified size yeah that's
just down a point there we go there so
that's that's one tracking level this
looks good to me that looks better uh
and then you want me to try a size
yeah just down a point
oh sorry that's up uh
uh that looks pretty good to me
okay so and by the way those are talics
for the uh you know function the pattern
names yeah that's some kind of faux
italic presumably
um
um it's I mean it's whatever the system
is giving us for this font which sorry I
just don't remember off top of my head
entirely possible to synthesize yes
[Music]
um
see
okay
I'm a little bit worried with this
change because frequently people do
comment out a piece of code
and it changes it a lot so I would also
prefer it with keep
the
sides and not
maybe so change the sides
size but you're not worried about the
about the tracking not so much but the
the sides
well I don't know let's try just to take
a piece of that code
John and comment it right now
no not that one a bigger one
go ahead
it's not that bad actually I think could
you unselect it please yeah I I just
wanted to toggle it again without the
scroll bar jumping so you can see the
difference
okay now now toggle it back again
and unselect
doesn't seem that terrible I mean uh we
should can we see this at 100 please not
magnified
Jeremy what do you think about the color
of the the comments
why do we go other than gray I don't
know it feels like we're fighting
wanting them to be seen versus not
wanting them to see scene I think it
depends on the use case can we try just
plain gray John yeah like gray level 0.4
or something
uh for the comments you said yep
okay
seconds
I feel like the code with like English
commentary that's a different use case
than just timing and out a piece of you
know non-functional code or some older
piece of code right that's great
foreign
[Music]
I think I may be running into some kind
of bug here because this is
oh no no no
no
sorry sorry sorry I I I see what's going
on okay
and now I want to see some of Crystal's
code here I was tweaking the wrong value
a level of 0.4 yep there we go
I think it looks better than the green
and I do too
want to change the grade level Jeremy
uh that's it on my machine
this looks okay but I'd want to see it
on my Mac to be sure yeah okay and we
have to see how it agrees with the gray
levels of the brackets and things yeah
okay let's see some of Christopher's
code
catego chunks
actually let me let me look at some of
those other ones sorry you were just
scrolling down we just look at the
the which one the Michaels Michael's no
no no the shaw 256 one yeah that's
Christopher's yeah
ah strings are gray
that may be what we wanted to
distinguish in the in the comments
the problem is here that that seeing
this was so much
blue could you switch off the blue
be black
if I can find it yes um
oops um
now I mean what happens to Output here
if you just take one of these things and
say hold of that whole giant like hold
of that width or something and let's
just see it as output see what it looks
like
uh
uh like this for example they'll take
the whole width
I'm just sticking the hole
that's just weird looking
I mean so that doesn't have any of the
of the I don't even understand why it
doesn't have any of the syntax coloring
in it oh because output cells never have
syntax coloring
I mean it's an easy thing to play with
but it's a decision that you know we
made a long time ago which I think is a
pretty good decision
maybe for brackets it's not the right
decision here I mean because that's it's
surprisingly unreadable in that case
okay can you scroll down through some
more of this code yeah and I can uh that
was that was it there wasn't that much
all right okay can we see um did Germany
have sample code there wait a minute
that was yeah there's some big chunks at
the bottom of mine
yeah so let's take a look
okay so
um
let's see
like around this is what you're thinking
no it's even more there's you know what
less are you able to just make this a
narrower notebook there you go
yeah
there we go ah here we go I think that's
what you're looking for Stephen yep
yeah
boy it's pretty hard to read what would
happen if we increase the line spacing
code is pretty hard to read though
I mean I think it's just that the format
the it's like unformatted
yeah I'm not sure how how easily that
could be helped
I mean this is hard to read this no yeah
I mean would you say the same thing
about math well probably it's different
because math is usually human really
human written for us this is sort of
semi
this is sort of semi machine
did you did you make it did you increase
the line space uh no I didn't but uh let
me just uh remind myself what the
current numbers are so I know
um
see
uh
zero two okay
um
so uh do
you know figuring it up
um
I thought I was changing it but it does
not seem to be changing so let me just
do it this way uh
there we go
to be slightly smaller please uh
um okay so that's just a tick above what
it was originally yeah no just so what
are the parameter values
the previous multiplier was 1.1 I ticked
it up to 1.2
that's 1.2 yeah this is 1.2
go to 1.4
too much I think
I mean this code is really hard to read
okay 1.3
okay let's scroll through some other
code please
okay
um
I did you do it globally no I did not uh
that's that was what I was struggling
with is I didn't remember where this was
coming from but uh but I can change
anything else you want
changed I mean that one is going to
already have some
uh just go
up I mean that that seems to me
at 1.3 was okay but this may go crazy if
you have the linear is that 1.3 there
it's now 1.3 I just changed it
Thomas or not I think
you scroll to a different one
uh scroll up here we go
this is unchanged this is
that was the change
there we go
well that's better it might be
Jeremy uh Christopher others
it's better for this case just have to
balance this versus you know smaller
chunks
well let's look up some for something
that's a two-line chunk could you go
scroll up please sure uh
uh see some like this yeah that one and
then make the line width smaller
increase the size that's just that's the
increase size now make the line look
smaller
yeah where was it sorry which one was it
uh the selected one here
and that's the 1.3 case that's 1.3 yeah
looks okay to me
um
we need to think about comments versus
strings
and what we can do there I think the
strings look pretty good in Gray
what can we do with the comments
well the tracking helps because we're
not
are we we're not the tracking for the
strings as the same as the tracking for
the for the function correct correct
okay if you scroll up put in this thing
please
yeah it needs that 1.3 for that one at
the top it's obscure try try changing
that again to 1.3 I'll change both of
these
it's better
honestly this looks pretty good to me
you know there's a few glitches we're
noticing here
okay Michael my feeling is that
um
uh
parenz okay braces I claim should be the
darker gray
do you agree or disagree what
friends I guess should also be the
darker gray because they are necessary
you you have to yeah
um
Association brackets probably like the
um sorry braces and prints you said yeah
braces and parents are the darker one so
the only one that's really lighter is
the square brackets
I want to go to arrows like the braces
they should be dark gray yeah
and these operators just need to be
clean the multi-character operators just
need to be cleaned they should be black
I think
I mean I admit that some operators like
at at could conceivably be gray Michael
what do you think about that
oh some of them I would be a little bit
concerned
well let's talk about which is which
I mean to me at an ad hat go ahead and
slash at I considered to be the same
but do you think dark gray that seems
right to me yeah I I think this is fine
but I mean something like a slash is
obviously black just a single slash
or plus sign is black
do you agree
what about
slash slash it
should go gray just for consistency the
whole thing not trust yeah yeah yeah
so I'm saying that that these things
which are essentially structural
operators
that are sort of
morally similar to brackets should be
the dark gray color
brackets themselves should be the light
gray color yeah
but but then Ed is morally similar to
square brackets
I know but it should be a darker gray
okay
yeah I think the
moral similarity is is breaking down
yeah and the colon equals should be
black
yeah that was that was I was trying to
think whether it might be a difference
of Single Character operators versus
multi-character operators but I realize
colon equal you don't want
to be different
from Plus
Sandra is asking should the vertical
spacing caused by explicitly using n to
be different from the one caused by
overflows but by by line wrapping
thank you
I
don't think so
uh all right so so you know
um I mean this maybe speaks a little
less elegant code but
um as as you're well aware I mean we
have this situation where you know you
might have multiple inputs you know one
plus one and two plus two and these are
in the same cell but they actually
create two outputs yeah which I hate yep
uh but uh you know one could imagine
having some kind of uh uh visible
delimiter to kind of magnificential flew
you in that these are magnificent
like a dotted line yeah yeah
I think that'll be great
so I can I mean also remember what's
really going on there is that there's an
N3 that's implicit
exactly maybe that maybe that's where we
should do something we can have
could we get an N3
in there
uh
uh yes
uh because it's just an annotation to
the cell and we just have to put another
annotation on that side right right uh
the yeah there was a bit of a technology
problem around this uh
uh but that was uh that was kind of
solved a couple versions ago
um okay well then I would strongly favor
that I I'm not sure that with with
actually I mean the you know the
technology problem was related to the
what we did to solve the line numbering
in the package editor okay okay I got
another comment if you can put an
annotation can't you just increase the
space between the things which are
distinct
yeah
and that would be fine I mean when I say
annotation I'm including that sort of
possibility yeah okay but I think that
will be fine that together with the fact
that when you actually evaluate you get
different in numbers that will be just
fine yeah that means if you if you
might not be totally obvious in just a
two input case with lines that don't
wrap
I understand that but it's better than
nothing so it will be much more obvious
when you evaluate and and something
something related that came across my
radar recently uh someone making this
sort of mistake uh and here the syntax
coin is helping you a bit you know the
the colon equal being magenta telling
you that that's not a complete
expression uh but we could maybe
emphasize this sort of thing even more
we could
look I think
uh
look percent modernization somehow
relates to all of that I'm so keen on
percent modernization you are going to
start working on this since I can find
any freaking time you know it's all the
priorities uh
yeah
okay
frankly I'd rather work on that than
some of the other things that I'm asked
to work on well fair enough okay what
else do we need to cover we're going to
run out of time here what else do we
need to cover in this meeting well okay
so
um
the I mean there's a question of what
if anything we're going to do for 13-3
I'm going to have this in there somehow
yeah so so so the the distinct you know
some operators with this color and some
operators of that color we're not going
to do that for 13.3
um
so you know there's a partial thing so
then then I suppose it should just be a
style sheet
uh which will which we will not
advertise yet right so so right now
right now it is a an environment
um and uh and just for your purpose we
also you know through and you know a
menu item in here
um but all the menu item does is it just
creates a notebook with that environment
sets I don't think we should have the
menu item yet if we're not ready with
all these features okay
okay I think we should have a style
environment
okay well I'm yeah that's fine working
out again
throwing the environment in 13-3 and it
may not be fully baked yet but you know
it can be there
could you throw in a elegant print too
uh yeah yeah I can do that okay
um
yes yes elegant print would be very
worthwhile
okay well I mean we clearly need to
incrementally is this pack that
updatable at all
uh uh not as presently implemented
um because I mean we should yeah this is
this is an important thing this is going
to be a big win
and I can guarantee that I'm going to be
asking you for this for things that I'm
writing and so on to render this way
well and of course I mean I'm only going
to deliver to you the desktop front end
for you know web Cloud whatever we're
going to pull in other people
right who need to be informed about this
going on
yeah
all right well I think this is uh this
is good I think anybody wants to make
any further comments here we do need to
think some more about well I think we've
we've figured out something about the
comments although maybe they need to go
a slightly different gray Jeremy what do
you think about that
I can try it I'm not convinced it might
not look intentional
right
fair enough
well I think the tracking change and the
size change will help
um
I'll look at that maybe we can tone back
the current color just a little more
desaturation of the blue
and it's not as loud I'm not sure why
the background setting didn't work I
would consider that a bug
that having been said I'm not sure the
change in the background is the right
call well but Jeremy's point is it's
going to be too shrink wrapped around
the characters yeah it's always way too
tight that is true that is true yes
right
okay uh good stuff thanks guys and see
you later okay bye